okay welcome back you recognize this you
know we all go to the snack machine the
vending machine to get something quick
to eat but there's one in the valley
that allows you to give back bianca
holman joining us now in downtown
summerlin to show us this unique vending
machine hi bianca
[Music]
there are 10 of these across the world
and we've got one of them right here in
las vegas you make a selection grab your
card swipe and you've made a difference
here in the valley
imagine dragons dan reynolds made the
first donation to kick off the return of
the light of the world giving machine
this starts the holiday giving season
ensuring no one goes without basic
necessities the giving machine gives you
a chance to buy a variety of basic
necessities for local charities with a
swipe of your credit or debit card
non-profits like communities and schools
of nevada i care for kids three square
and others they're so excited about
having the giving machines open again
it's such a great opportunity for
families and people to come down
together as groups of friends in 2019
the machine raised more than 800
thousand dollars it's not just about
helping a child see the board or it's
helping them see their future you know
we really want to support these children
and set them up for success in life
and clear vision is just one way to do
that
so this giving machine will be here
november 3rd and it will remain here in
downtown summerlin until january 3rd
2022 the onkaholman live local now